Graham Hill I'm VP of interactive for
planet green which is a initiative of
discovery communications i started back
in 2004 and started in barcelona
actually a lot of the talks about it
were initially in new york and i thought
about it for many years but i ended up
dating a Spanish woman and when we lived
all over the world for a number of years
so I ran it from everywhere essentially
so like an online software that anyone
can login to from from anywhere was was
critical and we built a virtual team
literally all over the world to the to
the point that even now I haven't met at
least half of the people in person yet
have quite deep relationships with them
so the internet was was absolutely
critical otherwise I would have had to
stay here and we also never had an
office so well I think it's been a
really radical change its moved from
needing to live in one place and work in
an office where with all of your
colleagues to really be able to live
anywhere around the world and work very
easily with a virtual team of people so
it's it's transformed it's made a lot
less expensive and it's a it's a made it
a lot more interesting I think people
are realizing that they can move around
and enjoy they're able to work and work
remotely often earning Western wages or
earning high wages and paying having low
low expenses or moving from the winter
to the summer and so there are a lot of
advantages to it also to sort of get it
getting away so I think digital nomads
are just people who take advantage of
digital technology in order to continue
to do their work but in a location that
might be better for
financial reasons or temperature reasons
or maybe they're just spending time with
family or friends well I think they're
probably two big areas that it's changed
one is just on demand software so sort
of the google docs etc of the world i
think that like was computing in the
cloud I i love it I think it's I think
it's amazing that I've installed
reinstalled uninstalled way too much
software and so I really love the
simplicity of cloud cloud computing and
Google Docs and and and gmail and any
sort of sort of online software that I
don't have to install on my computer
that I can access from anywhere around
the world I say that's a big one the
other one that's really changed is
communication so skype and skype is a
big one both and other just instant
messaging platforms i think that's
really huge and voice over IP and and
video that's really transform things may
it's made it very easy and inexpensive
to communicate with the big team from
around the world and so I'd say that's a
really that's a really big one and then
mobile phones that do email and instant
messaging and and all that also really
transform things they made it so that
you can get away with having this tiny
little thing in your pocket for the most
part which is great well I think one of
the great things about it is you don't
get sidetracked and in I think it's hard
not to get sidetracked into are they
male or a female are they young are they
old like what are they like in person so
it's really all about their resume and
the references and how you and how you
interact and so I really like that fact
you can hire someone you're not even
really sure whether they're a man or a
woman like it's great so it's so I like
it that that you you judge you're forced
to judge people with with only only that
part
and you're forced to communicate really
well and i don't know i think it's i
think it's great and that's always so
exciting to meet them in person than
that in evitable e they turn to be just
as cool in person as they as they seem
to be when you're communicating
communicating with them online I think
it's great anyone that does it and you
know I think it's a I think it's a
beautiful thing people decide okay this
you know I can I can actually live in
the country for for a period and do my
work and get paid City wages and really
sort of change my life it's just it's a
lot more directed it's a lot more open
and a lot more sort of freeing people
just really designing their lives and
trying to figure out you know what
what's really best for me and I just
sort of getting it done so I mean I
think they're there a ton of people and
I think people that have the jobs that
they can that allow them to do that are
very very lucky I'm the nice thing about
computers these days is they're becoming
the center for everything so it's here
it's your pictures it's your music it's
your movies it's your workplace you know
it's your mapping system it's your phone
directory it's just so it's all it's all
there and that's that's the great thing
so it's simple little laptop and your
plug and some adapters and you're you're
generally good to go it's all integrated
so that's all you need you don't need
much it's great it's very free
you